Ellen DeGeneres gets Jennifer Aniston
and Derek Hough to open up my husband
who's been away for almost a year
surprised me on Thanksgiving came home
from Germany for the turkey with the
turkey Jen dished on her sweet
Thanksgiving surprise from hubby Justin
Theroux and spoke candidly about that
powerful op IDI she penned earlier this
year we have to support each other
especially at this time to love each
other to support and should be proud of
women and of whatever your choices in
life it's up to us what makes us happy
and fulfilling then Derick dropped by
and talked about serving as long time
pal Mark Ballas is a best man he asked
me 17 years ago to be his best man we
were 14 years old and so there's a lot
of pressure actually Derick also dished
on hairspray live he's playing Tony
Collins coming up and it's it's a
challenge I mean the extent of this the
the magnitude of it it's I mean it's
like you know it's like filming a
full-length feature film you know live
before your eyes and you know not have
it all down yet no I got it down but but
there's a few lines that I just kind of
you know slip my lines over the musical
hits our TV screens next week it's
pretty pretty exciting
you